immer wieder werden in Fernsehreportagen
Gesprächspartner Zeitzeugen und andere
zufällig Beteiligte bis zur
Unkenntlichkeit weggepixelt wie deren
Leben aber nach dieser visuellen
Anonymisierung aussieht will niemand
sehen
ja ich würde meine Frau sehr gerne mal
wieder auf den Mund küssen aber ihr Kopf
ist so grob gepixelt dass sie die Mund
gar nicht finden kann so kann und darf
es einfach nicht weitergehen der
Bayerische Rundfunk hat darum ein
Spendenkonto eingerichtet die Aktion ein
Gesicht für dich kümmert sich schnell
und unbürokratisch um gepixelte Menschen
um ihr schlimmes Schicksal mit einfachen
Mitteln wenigstens ein bisschen zu
lindern
naja es ist nicht ganz so selbe aber es
hilft ungemein